my job was to stand behind the register
at my dad's store my whole teenage years
it was slow like we didn't have that
many customers so I was able to watch
people and that's what I did I wasn't
bored there was no phones back there I
would read the wine spectator and then
as soon as ding as soon as the door
opened I would watch remember
when I was finally 22 and came from
college and it was my turn to run the
business the first thing I did I redid
the whole store basically my dad's store
was called Shoppers Discount Liquors but
I wanted to be Wine Library and then
what I did was the right side that you
never would go towards I basically
stopped merchandising there because you
weren't going to see it anyway I made
this something called the top 10 it just
said top 10 but because it was
merchandise is one 2 three the number
one wine sold like f it had no context
and then at the register I made it all
premium half bottles of champagne and
wine so instead of people grabbing like
9 Cent peanuts at the register they were
grabbing like $7 half bottles of wine
and then that skill set got me to day
one on wine library.com to care about
Shopper cart Dynamics day one